it's near the end of Parliament special
committee on tax rulings set up after
the lux leaks on multinationals tax
avoidance and MEP s had a chance to
question the European Commission mr.
jonker particularly on his role as
Luxembourg's former prime minister are
you ready to report systematically which
role you played in the tax haven aspects
of Luxembourg if help me Luxembourg can
do still deftly oriental tune with after
intertidal leftover modern food instead
he stressed the need for fairness and
tax transparency the motion teri aankhen
play los golpes ash fiscal arrest parcel
is a composite de L'Amour contradict
were from any mep is one key demand is
for member states automatically to
exchange information on special tax
rulings just lower duncan's toy at fixer
vine door design for hand to confess
cash dead the arden for other m eps the
address by mr. Jung ko was a whitewash
he has missed the opportunity to rebuild
his credibility in tax matters in his
new role as president of the Commission
mep s will vote on the special
committee's recommendations in november